Nathaniel is with us in Toledo hi
Nathaniel how are you good how about you
better than I deserve what's up so right
now I am in my second semester in
college at a local community college
Owens Community and I'm looking at
transfer to the Ohio State University in
the August in the fall um majoring in
accounting they kind of switched around
on me just to make sure I'd be
successful Ohio State and I was really
wanting to not have take any loans out
my tuition tuition there was about
$10,000 per year housing about 12 grand
I don't know if I can swing twenty-two
thousand dollars right now I'm sitting
on about nine hundred dollars probably
total in life savings checking account I
just had to purchase books and stuff so
right now I have a job looking to get
another job interview coming up on
Monday with the YMCA maybe even get a
third job over the summer at a golf
course and I'm just trying to bang out
ten thousand dollars over the summer so
I don't have to take out a loan so
that's it let's looking for some good
advice on how to do it I think that's
exactly what you do um ten thousand
dollars is 800 bucks a month and that's
what you've got to continue to earn
while you're in school and you got to
figure out your housing as well so it's
looking like it's looking like you need
a couple grand a month continually so
how can you do that well you can make
fifteen hundred a month delivering
pizzas five nights a week
yep and you know you can't deliver dough
huh do what I cannot deliver though
because uh insurance will cover my car
if I deliver and they don't carve the
business I work for they don't have like
their own car so I have to use my own
car so I cannot deliver but try to make
some tips change insurance insurance
that I have to switch to progressive and
my parents looked into the surprises web
service so they don't want to do that
well let's shop around a little bit I
mean there's other people that have
insurance anyway there's all kinds of
things you can do to earn money and I
would not say I don't think you can make
it on minimum wage
you're not gonna work enough hours and
go to school on minimum wage to pull
this off but
maybe you start your own business I
don't know cutting grass delivering
whatever walking dogs I don't care but
yeah you're right through the summer
you've got to pile up some cash and get
started and you've got to continue to
work to get through the other thing I
want you to do start looking for
scholarships and apply I want you to
apply for like a hundred scholarships in
the next 90 days man you'll get turned
out you'll get turned down for most of
them but if you get one it's worth the
trouble I mean one for a thousand
dollars if it took you if it took you
ten hours well that's 100 bucks an hour
you know it took you ten hours to apply
for a hundred scholarships well then you
now you got your new job and then your
new job then is applying for
scholarships but if you'll keep your
costs down your housing costs down and
your transportation costs down if
there's anything your parents can do to
chip in that's fine but you do not need
to get a loan this is doable it's it's
really reachable and you may have to
adjust your insurance on your car I
don't know you got to decide what you're
gonna do but you find a way to do it and
you just take the option of borrowing
off the table that's not an option so I
have to find a way and then that will
change the way your brain works towards
solving the problem